foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror doing another book review as we
do on this little Series so Jeremy Ray
uh this is an author I actually had not
encountered before and I kind of went
and read his bio and he's actually like
found some success mainly I feel like as
a playwright and he's won some awards I
think for uh his screenplays and stuff
as well but according to him his first
love is doing kind of short prose short
fiction now he's not exclusively a
horror writer because he likes to kind
of hop genres which is fine however uh
his 2021 Novella petrified women which
is what we're talking about today is
undoubtedly a horror story and it really
does uh pack a hell of a wallop into its
very very brief 92 pages so in this
we're following a young woman named
Harley now up to this point in her life
uh she's had some really unfortunate
look with men all of her boyfriends like
all of her prior boyfriends have sucked
in one way or another and never in the
fun way and one of them matter of fact
Christopher even sexually assaulted her
and this is an event that still uh you
know there's a lot of lingering trauma
surrounding it I don't think it ever
specifies like how long ago it was but
I'm assuming it was fairly recent
um one of the main things too is that
not only was it like really bad when it
happened but she's kind of traumatized
by the fact that she froze up and she
didn't do anything to stop it or she
didn't do enough to stop it so she feels
like it was like her fault very very
common uh for survivors of sexual
assault uh so and I kind of feel like
this
really like heartbreaking
self-doubt that this character is
constantly feeling and this fervent wish
that she has to like rewrite history
rewrite the past so it came out
differently
um is really really excellently conveyed
in the story and it gives like a real
depth to Harley's character and when
you're reading it you really feel kind
of like an immediate empathy with her
like because of her the way that her
thoughts process about this thing that
happened to her in the past but in spite
of all that she's still convinced that
her current boyfriend Aiden is different
he's just really really sweet he's
really supportive
um you know and he's nothing at all like
those other losers that she's dated up
to this point now Harley's best friend
is a psychotherapist named Shelly and
Shelley does not like Aiden at all uh
seeing nothing but red flags but Harley
is evidently so desperate to like pick a
keeper this time maybe I kind of feel
like she's trying to prove to herself
that she's not irreparably broken like
it's like hey I can pick a good one you
know what I mean that she's she's just
so desperate to do that that she pretty
much downplays or sugar coats all of his
odd behavior now some of this odd
behavior uh revolves around his artwork
uh you know there's nothing odd about
being an artist of course but Aiden
sculptures are a little bit strange
um he carves these very realistic
life-size sculptures of women out of
wood and all of the women are kind of
inevitably uh portrayed in various poses
usually like sadness or distress of some
kind or supplication something like that
um and at one point like Harley's like
why don't you ever sculpt like a woman
that looks happy or powerful or
something like that and he's like oh
well because most of the buyers are men
and this is what they want
so Harley actually kind of thought they
were creepy at first like when her and
Aiden first started dating but she kind
of soon developed an affinity with them
and calls them by name and talks to them
when she goes over to his place as if
they're alive and he even like gave her
one of them which is called Dolores like
it it still like stays in his apartment
but she like talks to it when she's over
there like as though it's a real woman
now on its own obviously the weird art
wouldn't amount to much but the much
more alarming aspect of Aiden's
character is his love of pulling really
elaborate and sometimes actually really
cruel pranks on Harley and he said it's
implied that he's pulled them on his
previous girlfriends as well and these
aren't just like your run-of-the-mill
hey jump out and say Boo kind of pranks
either these are like really like
complicated [ __ ] I don't know they're
like a big thing examples of them
include like tampering with a test to
make Harley think she's pregnant paying
a friend to dress up like a Bigfoot like
and they're on a camping trip and he
like Bigfoot like hauls Harley out of
the tent like he's gonna eat her faking
an altercation with a waiter like and
the waiter supposedly stabs Aiden to
death it's pranks like that you know
what I mean it's like a jackass level
and Beyond these pranks as they probably
would in real life cause Harley like a
great deal of anxiety and sometimes
trigger like PTSD flashbacks to her
prior rape but because Aiden is so
perfect otherwise she kind of just
assures herself that well this is just
the way that he expresses affection and
she even tries to get into the ACT
herself like attempting some pranks of
her own like to get back at him and she
tells Shelley that pulling these very
vicious jokes on one another that's
simply their love language that's how
they like Express you know what I mean
so you can kind of see like how far God
she is like how how much she's trying to
convince herself that this guy is okay
so the entirety of the story in fact um
and as I said it's quite short It
Centers on Harley trying to Stage kind
of like the mother of all pranks on
Aiden they even have like a competition
like she always loses because her pranks
are kind of lame or he figures them out
beforehand because he's kind of like a
master at this so they have like a list
of like which ones were the scariest uh
like a ranking on the refrigerator so
she wants to you know do the mother of
all pranks like against him and like get
back at him finally and do like a really
really good one that gets him good now
it's his birthday so that's another
reason for her to do it
so unbeknownst to him she actually
swiped his apartment key and made a copy
of it and then returned it to him like
without him knowing about it so while
he's out on his birthday she lets
herself into his apartment and she's
going to like dress up as a Prowler like
she's got like uh you know all the black
clothes and she's got like fake muscles
underneath and it's like she's got
pantyhose like to put over her face so
he doesn't like recognize her and like
even shoes with like lips in him so she
looks like a big dude
so yeah so she's gonna dress up as a
Prowler and pop out of his bedroom
closet like with a terrifying Roar and
like scare the [ __ ] out of him and she
even brought like balloons and like an
ice cream cake and stuff like that so
after this big scare she's gonna be like
hey it's just me and then they're gonna
like have a little party or whatever so
that's what she's planned now the first
part of this scheme uh goes goes pretty
well and Harley gets into the apartment
just fine she gets into the closet and
she's in there kind of like waiting
impatiently for Aiden's arrival
but as you might imagine things don't
turn out quite the way she expected them
to uh because Aiden actually gets home
but he isn't alone and Harley ends up
seeing a completely different side of
him than the one that she's used to so
the rest of the story essentially plays
out kind of like a cat and mouse game
kinda and Aiden's previous history of
doing these elaborate pranks come into
play as neither Harley nor the person
reading the story is entirely sure
what's real and what's not so it's
almost kind of like the book is like
gaslighting you the way that Harley got
gaslighted now just a heads up uh if
you're bothered by stories about sexual
assault there is actually like a warning
at the beginning of the novella but um
as the author is apparently also a
sexual assault Survivor the descriptions
in the book are actually really
Tastefully done I thought very
insightful actually like the way uh you
know people think about their trauma
like afterward and very very sensitively
portrayed it's not all that graphic but
if something like that is going to upset
you then just be warned that there is
something like that in here so this was
a really really great like impactful
story I think it was like really good
partially because it was so short that
it had so much impact it's actually
structured kind of like a really really
good episode of like a real suspenseful
like Thriller type TV show because it
has like a real limited scope like
pretty much the whole thing takes place
entirely like in Aiden's apartment more
or less like there's other things going
on outside too but
um and it only has like really a handful
of characters so it has like this real
intimacy to it and I also really liked
that you had this real persistent doubt
about the reality of the events as they
were unfolding so that really increased
like the anxiety because like I said the
main character Harley who's it's not in
the first person but it's kind of like
her from her point of view like inside
her head and she's never sure like if
what she's saying is like real or fake
and then you're not really sure either
and that like really UPS the tension
um it starts out as more of a thriller
as I mentioned
um as Harley's kind of like waiting in
the closet and starts remembering back
to like the escalating pranks that Aiden
has pulled on her pulled on her but then
when Aiden comes home it kind of like
hits the gas and goes speeding into like
full-on horror territory
um so yeah it's really really well paced
and because it's really short it can
kind of be read in just one real
breathless sitting and that's the way
that I would advise that you read it
that's the way I read it and like I said
it's just like a really good
episode of a TV show that's like really
suspenseful so I think it's better to
like read it all in one sitting
um I'll definitely be reading more of
Jeremy Ray's stuff in the future I've
actually heard a lot of really good
things about he's uh it's not a horror
story but he wrote like a short story
called the house plant uh that's like
it's more like a contemporary fiction
type of thing
um that I've heard was actually like
really really good and like really
emotionally resonant I guess so I'll
probably get around to reading that as
well that's very all that's also very
short I think it's only 30 pages or so
but uh for now this one is a definite
recommend for horror fans and I think
even though it doesn't take place on
Halloween or anything like that I think
like the focus on pranks and things like
that I think really makes it a good read
like particularly around like you know
the Halloween season like or fall or
something like that it just gave me that
kind of vibe so yeah I would definitely
recommend it it's on Kindle unlimited if
you have that you can read it for free
and like I said it's only 90 90 odd
pages so it probably only take like an
hour or two to read and it's really
really good I really do recommend it so
that'll do it for this tomes of Terror I
will see you guys again on the next one
bye